in today's money watch we're talking
about the massive spike in rents and
home prices across the country and
anyone who's looked to move in the past
several months knows exactly what we're
talking about as of april the average
cost of rent has jumped more than 16
percent from the same time last year and
the price of homes has increased more
than 34 percent over the past two years
we brought in cbs business analyst jill
schlesinger to give us some advice on
how to handle these situations it is not
pretty what what's going on here i mean
this harkens back to like
2005-6 right before something else
happened you know a lot of people have
been asking me about this very question
like wow if prices are up almost 35
in two years is this actually a housing
bubble could we see something horrible
happen things are different so the good
news is that banks haven't gone crazy
lending to anybody with a heartbeat and
a lot of people are actually putting
more money down act to get a home
because there have been these bidding
wars so it is daunting and it's tough
but i think from a housing bubble burst
perspective we're probably not looking
at that but i think price increases are
going to slow down and i do think there
are some markets that might even see
declines in the near term well why are
they going up in the future
so you know it is a supply and demand
issue right so we know that coming into
covid there weren't a lot of homes for
sale and this is actually an echo of the
2008-2009 crash because all these
builders put homes up and they got
killed they really needed to build more
homes but there was no financing so we
come in short of homes covet hits and
what happens boom everybody says get me
out of my small space i'm working from
home and they drive prices up so it's
been a supply end demand problem it
seems everything has blamed on covert
but say your lease is coming up and
you're up for renewal what are your
options well i think this is an
important moment because when we talk
about housing that's one part of the the
of the economy but renting is a lot of
people and a lot of people can't afford
to buy a home and they are facing these
near 17
increases from a year ago now let's put
that in context for a second because
there's actually a weird covered part of
this too during covent rents went down
yeah so now huge deals right and so that
now a lot of landlords say to me hey
i've got to catch up like i had two
years where i couldn't get this so let's
say your lease is coming up first thing
you actually want to do go to your
landlord say i love it here i want to
stay here i am a good payer i'm so great
okay let's just say the landlord's like
well too bad yes so that now you start
to say well can i lock in a longer
period of time for my lease instead of
one year maybe two years could you delay
the increase maybe till later in the
year maybe you're going to get some more
money maybe you can get some appliances
are they open to that they you know a
lot of them are especially a lot of the
smaller landlords because they don't
want to see turnover before you tell
your landlord to like beat it with that
remember it's expensive to move so i
would be very careful even when you're
buying jill that idea of moving now or
weight and you play this game i have
friends who are doing it right now
what's the advice do you wait do you
stay there's a really weird moment where
we're in right now because not only are
prices high but we also know mortgage
rates have increased dramatically so we
were below 3 for a 30-year fixed-rate
mortgage we're now above 5
that's made the cost of ownership much
higher by more than about 6 300 for the
median household in the median home so
that's a lot so here's the deal if
you're going to buy you still have to
run the numbers you're not off the hook
if you can afford higher mortgage rates
sure you can make this work i think that
most people are dissuaded just because
there aren't so many homes for sale and
it's just a bummer you're going to spend
your whole summer going to open houses
over and over i know it's tough but
again look at that rent because one of
the adverse effects of inflation is
rents can go up even more so your fixed
cost of housing is different than your
variable cost for a rent i mean go ahead
no i was just going to say you're
talking about interest rates i remember
when five percent was a deal now we're
talking about but i mean at some point
with interest rates rising do you see a
cap well we are actually seeing a
slowdown in housing activity we got all
this new data out in the last week on
housing market numbers for existing in
new homes and definitely activity is
slowing down mortgage applications
slowing down but you're right i mean for
a lot of households five percent isn't
so bad and also we know a lot of people
who already own homes and they're
trading maybe they're trading up they're
putting a lot of money down they have
got a lot of equity in their home right
and when they make the move they may not
need such large mortgages so that's
that's a good thing uh one last bit here
when you think about mortgages remember
in the bad old days when we were doing
the housing crisis we talked about
adjustable rate mortgages interest well
they're coming back are they and because
people are really freaking out that
prices are up and i can't afford these
fixed rates i would be careful because
remember what is the lesson of the
housing crisis of the 2000s you don't
get into a mortgage that you cannot
afford over the long term and those
things can jump on you so just be
careful out there and maybe relax have a
good summer when i went to go buy my
first house i thought if you have the
mortgage payment you're good and then
they said well you have to have a
deposit i go well where am i supposed to
get that
and they said oh you're not supposed to
have that
mortgage insurance
do you have a mother and a father ma'am
thank you jill thank you